les annonces de chiots à vendre sur
internet se multiplient et vous avez
bien lu
les prix demandés atteindre plusieurs
milliers de dollars jusqu'à 6000 $ pour
certaines races depuis le début de la
pandémie on a remarqué une augmentation
du nombre d'adoptions des chiens est
clairement c'est parce que les gens
s'ennuient va s'occuper donc que c'est
une bonne chose pour sa vie de les
refuges il ya des gens qui en profite
présentement pour vendre des animaux sur
internet
au delà du prix ou de la valeur réelle
et qu'on a un chien des fichiers 11,3
des dizaines de messages pour ce chien
là les enclos ne restent pas vides
longtemps ces temps ci à la spc a une
bonne nouvelle mais la présidente
s'inquiètent de voir un si grand nombre
de chiens à vendre sur internet
c'est surtout troublant parce qu'on
s'est pas souvent d'où viennent ces
animaux là on connaît pas leur génétique
et les gens qui adoptent ces animaux là
elles sont pas nécessairement bien
conseillés non plus savent pas dans quoi
dans quoi ils s'embarquent et qui ont
trait que dans quelques mois ces animaux
leur se retrouve chez nous oui c'est
quelque chose qui nous fait par ses
annonces sur la toile font craindre le
pire
une nouvelle formule du scénario 2
points 0
orchestré par un réseau bien établi
vidéos mails chez une famille d'accueil
d'aubin qui sont ici qu'ils vont dire me
garde bien de chez nous on voit la coupe
les pilotes étaient des petits animaux
il doit se rendre chez parlophone quand
je vois les avants et les autres on va
te demander défendent adoptée par vote
de l'électricien
c'est une forme de sous traitance
d'usiné chine donc c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à détecter
c'est vraiment far west c'est dommage
parce que ce soit il ya des animaux au
bout de l'allée et des familles qui en
ai perdu contrôle je veux dire c'est
plus de 40 personnes que j'ai sur ma
liste nathalie obus élèves des chiens
depuis plus dix ans est une
professionnelle dans son milieu
elle est scandalisée de voir les prix
demandés déchirent sur internet
y'a rien qui justifie de l'augmentation
mon vétérinaire pour monter mamou l'oea
pour monter le club caennais n'a pas
monté mais il détaille la santé oms pour
monter pourquoi je monterai mépris parce
que il ya une dame mais je trouve ça
logique
elle précise que la demande de dépôt
n'est pas une pratique courante il
suggère de se méfier des éleveurs qui
refusent les visites sous prétexte de la
pandémie
ici marie michel lauzon radio-canada à
montréal